the leader of the Wagner mercenary group
is concerned the world thought that he
was in Belarus that's uh with the
suggestion is where he had found himself
after that coup attempt on Moscow well
it transpires he's not there at all and
in fact we're being told by the leader
of Belarus that he is in
Saint Petersburg which is his home City
along with President Putin of course
they've known each other for a very long
time used to work together in Saint
Petersburg his home has been raided in
Saint Petersburg the leader of the
Wagner group the latest we are hearing
from president lukashenko is that that
is where he is he is in Saint Petersburg